it was a really busy weekend in las
vegas jam-packed with
sports concerts entertainment all across
the las vegas valley the very first
country concert
rocked the legion stadium garth brooks
taking the stage saturday night
it was the first full capacity concert
at the venue
gar's wife fellow country singer tricia
yearwood even made
a special appearance as they did the
song
shallow together and brian those who
attended the concert describe the
parking and the transportation
to and from allegiant as a quote
nightmare
signage either was confusing or just
non-existent
as kate houston reports some attendees
say they will not
go back until changes are made i just
feel
like it wasn't as prepared as it should
have been
maggie walker has been waiting to see
garth brooks in concert since she was a
little girl
but that excitement quickly turned to
frustration when she had to abandon her
ride to the concert due to major traffic
and little direction from workers we got
out on the freeway
and started walking to the event center
it took it was about two miles
walker took this video showing a swarm
of people walking on hacienda avenue
she says it didn't help there was
record-breaking heat
i saw actually two ladies have to be
taken by stretcher
walked to an ambulance because they were
passing out from the heat
fans that drove described waiting for
more than an hour in line for parking
those getting dropped off say there was
not a designated area
even for those with handicap access like
raymond kovitz
i stopped you know 20 times along the
way
you know whatever i could rest against
to
have to sit and you know continue
forward another
feat or two the issues definitely caught
the attention of county commissioner
michael naft
he tells me he met with police fire and
public works
no doubt the traffic issues are ones we
have to learn from
moving forward naf says the stadium will
work on traffic control
signage and how they're communicating to
attendees we want it to be a fun
experience for people and certainly the
stadium wants people to come back again
and again and
part of that part of doing that is
making sure that they have a fun
experience and that it's not
dreadful to come and go from the stadium
kate houston 8 news now
yeah we were worried about that when we
warned a lot of our viewers on friday
multiple large events are planned for
this summer and that includes a
huge international soccer event at a
legion stadium
and of course a guns n roses concert
commissioner knapp says they plan to put
tents along hacienda avenue which was
kind of
transferred into a pedestrian bridge and
also have water available as people walk
over that bridge